Sebastian MALLABY: AI is going to
influence everything. It’s probably
the biggest event in human history
since the Industrial Revolution.
Janet HAVEN: I’m really much more concerned about
how automation will impact society at large.
Gabrielle SIERRA: Do you feel good
about where we’re heading with AI?
MALLABY: Maybe we need to invent a new
word here which is kind of a combination
of frightened and excited. I’m fri-sighted.
SIERRA: Welcome to Part II of our exploration into
the world of AI. In Part I we learned that
AI presents nearly unlimited possibilities
for scientific progress. And that it also,
theoretically, presents unlimited dangers.
SIERRA: Regardless of which you
believe, the fact stands that the
technology is evolving really quickly.
SIERRA: All of this sets up a classic situation
in which regulation will play an essential
role. Every country will have to decide for
itself how much to limit the potential
harms of AI, even if those regulations
could also slow down its development among
fierce international competition. And the
nature of the world we live in 10 or 20 years
from now could hang in the balance. What path
will the most powerful governments choose?
SIERRA: I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It
Matters. Today, how the world might regulate
AI before it begins regulating us.
SIERRA: Can you give us just a quick
lay of the land about AI regulation?
You know, what exists currently?
HAVEN: So at this point, in terms of actual
law that is specific to AI, I think the answer
is either nothing or close to nothing.
SIERRA: Back from part one of this two part
episode is Janet Haven. She’s the Executive
Director of the nonprofit research group Data
& Society. She’s also a member of President Joe
Biden’s National Artificial Intelligence
Advisory Committee, though it’s important
to note that her comments in this episode don’t
reflect the views of the committee itself.
HAVEN: This is an industry that has been
remarkably unconstrained from the outset.
One of the really clear interesting tropes
that has come through that is the widespread
agreement among policymakers that the essentially
non-regulation of social media in the earlier
2000s was a huge miss and a big mistake.
MALLABY: I think if the objective of the
regulation is not to suppress AI, but
rather to disclose the identity of an AI
that does something so you know it's machine
done, to maybe include some explainability,
confidence level, disclosures in the AI. I think
those sorts of regulations can create safety,
can create confidence, can create good use of AI,
whilst not trying to eliminate AI. I think if you
try to eliminate it, that's a fool's errand.
SIERRA: Also returning to the episode is Sebastian
Mallaby. He’s the senior fellow for international
economics at the council. He’s currently
writing a book on artificial intelligence.
MALLABY: It's just too useful. And the upsides of
AI are too compelling that if you try to eliminate
it, A, you are shooting yourself in the foot,
B, it'll be used somewhere else and you'll
fall behind and that's not a good outcome.
So countries should want to be part of AI.
They should want to embrace AI. They also just
should be thoughtful about actively managing the
downside. I think the key is yes to regulation,
but just make sure it's the right kind.
SIERRA: You know, we did an episode on the three
global internets. China's heavily restricted
system, the U.S.’s sort of free for all system,
and the EU’s regulated system with a focus
on privacy. Do you think that we'll see
similar splintering in the AI space?
MALLABY: Yes. I mean, I think the Chinese
will go their own way and the rest of the
world will develop its own set of rules.
And it'd be great to think that they
can be unified. But given the current
geopolitics, it doesn't seem very likely.
SIERRA: There’s a lot at stake for US companies as
lawmakers decide how to regulate. The government
knows that there’s serious money to be made from
innovation, and the United States has typically
been light handed in its regulation of the tech
industry, which is a major pillar of its economy.
On the other hand, the risks of AI are unique
and considerable, and American lawmakers are
increasingly aware of what can go wrong when tech
companies are left to regulate themselves.
HAVEN: I think it's really easy to assume that
people who are talking about regulation or
people who are in my position who study,
you know, the harms and the implications
of these technologies in society
are coming from an anti-tech perspective. It's
important to say that that isn't the case. And
I think that what we have the opportunity to do
at this moment is not just to regulate, but is to
consider how we create a different kind of social
contract that opens up space to imagine what AI in
the public interest looks like, what it could be
for our society, for the United States, globally,
that is truly beneficial. But I don't think that
that's easy or obvious how to do it. And so the
whole frame of the recent congressional hearing
that we saw with Sam Altman testifying was,
"We messed this up with social media, so now we
need to get it right with AI." You know, which is
interesting because it does suggest that there's
some momentum to take meaningful steps.
Sam Altman: My worst fears are that we cause
significant harm to the world. I think if this
technology goes wrong, it can go quite wrong,
and we want to be vocal about that. We want to
work with the government to prevent that from
happening. But we try to be very clear eyed
about what the downside case is and the
work we have to do to mitigate that.
SIERRA: Okay, let’s stop for a second and just
digest. AI is a world-changing technology,
and so far there is no corresponding
regulatory agency or body of law governing
its use in the United States. That’s wild!
But that doesn’t mean that the government
has been sitting on its hands entirely.
HAVEN: One of the policy tools that came out last
October, from the Office of Science and Technology
Policy is the blueprint for an AI Bill of Rights.
And what that laid out was five core principles
of protections that Americans should expect,
when interacting with an AI system.
Those five principles, just very briefly,
are safe and effective systems, algorithmic
discrimination protections, data privacy, notice
and explanation, and one that I think is really
intriguing, human fallback and intervention. So,
essentially, that if you receive a decision
or an output from an AI system that you don't
understand or that you disagree with, that you
should have a right to interact with a human,
which echoes the European Union's GDPR
position on human intervention.
SIERRA: GDPR - or the General Data Protection
Regulation - is the world’s strongest data
security and privacy law, implemented by
the European Union in 2018. One part of
this legislation requires human intervention
in some automated decision making. The U.S.
doesn’t have anything like it - but the AI
Bill of Rights could change that.
HAVEN: One of the things that I think is
really important that we're seeing happen
is that through an executive order called Further
Advancing Racial Equity a number of agencies are
flexing their powers that they currently
have to more actively regulate around AI.
So that particularly is through existing civil
rights law, which of course in the United States
we have civil rights protections, and those are
applicable to AI. So we're talking about the use
of AI systems in criminal legal systems, for
instance, predictive policing, risk assessment
scoring in courtrooms. Those use algorithmic
decision making systems, in some cases AI, and
have been shown to be ineffective in some cases,
harmful in others, again, to increase inequality.
So that is one area where we can see civil
rights law coming into play. Access to housing
is another area. The FTC is, of course, looking
at antitrust and anti-monopoly action, and they're
particularly looking at it through the lens of
commercial surveillance and data protection.
So looking at it very much from the beginning
of the chain. So where the data is coming from,
how we are collecting data. And there is a
theory around one particular governance tool,
the idea of data minimization - the collection of
the minimal amount of data rather than right now
where we're at, which is maximal data collection.
And also the limiting of retention of data, the
limiting of selling of data through data brokers.
So the whole question of how data is regulated is
beyond the narrow bands of privacy.
SIERRA: Is there a way to put the genie
back in the bottle or is this a situation
like nuclear technology where there's just
no way to get everyone to just drop a
dangerous technology all at once?
MALLABY: I think the nuclear analogy is terrific.
I mean, nuclear is also a technology that has
enormous destructive potential. But also
if you think about civilian nuclear power,
quite big upsides. And I think with nuclear, the
difference is that it was produced entirely by
governments at the beginning, whereas AI is being
produced entirely in the private sector. However,
there is an encouraging similarity between the
two, which is that the number of teams in the
world that are really cutting edge in AI is
not all that big. There's a whole different
debate about what if this is open sourced, then it
becomes very cheap. Once you have the open sourced
algorithmic code, it fits on a thumb drive and
somebody else can plug that thumb drive into a
laptop and start running generative AI models
because somebody else has trained it.
SIERRA: Open source refers to code that is
published publicly, and it can be modified and
distributed by anybody. This can be a good
thing. More than half of all academic papers
studying machine learning aka the process
that pushes AI toward higher capabilities,
have relied on open source software. But while
open source allows a larger group of people to
help refine AI, it also allows access to those
who would use it for destructive purposes.
MALLABY: That's a caveat that points to one
policy prescription. We shouldn't be allowing
open sourcing of these models. And since there
are only a small number of companies that are big
enough to train the models, those who do train
it need to hear soon from their governments,
you're not allowed to open source it because that
is sort of letting the genie out of the bottle,
and that's probably not a good idea.
SIERRA: Although there are no laws in the
United States yet that regulate AI, there are laws
aimed at fueling its development.
SIERRA: In 2022, President Biden signed
the CHIPS and Science Act, which invested
billions in U.S. semiconductor manufacturing
and discouraged allies from selling semiconductors
to China. And this paid off - as ChatGPT soared in
popularity in the first half of 2023, Nvidia,
the leading U.S. chipmaker, tripled in value,
reaching a $1 trillion valuation.
SIERRA: Progress on making AI safe, however,
has not materialized as quickly.
SIERRA: Okay, what are some other
holes in AI regulation?
HAVEN: We need to worry about
data privacy. In this country, we do not have a
federal comprehensive data privacy law, which is
extraordinary and leaves us open to enormous
vulnerabilities. I think we also, you know,
at the most basic level, people often don't know
when an AI system is being used. That creates huge
risk. And so we need approaches to understanding
when an AI system is being used so that people
understand what they're interacting with. We do
not at this point have a national AI strategy,
and that means that if we end up in a room with
a bunch of other countries and are trying to
hammer out some kind of agreements, that we are
not drawing on a base that is solid. I think
that we need to really understand the value of
international agreements on emerging issues.
SIERRA: Alright so then it pays to see
what other countries are up to. Last week,
the EU got one step closer to passing the EU AI
Act, a framework they first proposed in 2021 that
could be finalized by the end of this year.
Associated Press: We can build responsible AI for
the systemic risks that this can entail,
but also thinking of everyday citizens,
consumers, businesses, institutions.
CNN: This is huge and this regulation by
the EU could act as a model for
lots of other governments who are
also trying to figure this out right now.
SIERRA: The act would create a suite of AI rules,
including the disclosure of copyrighted
material and restrictions on AI surveillance.
Firms that don’t comply with its regulations would
face steep fines: up to 6% of their global annual
revenue. This proposal has already made waves
across the AI industry and could even prevent some
AI tools from being available in the region.
MALLABY: There's a bit of a sort of unifying thing
where the Europeans write the regulations, but
then they get adopted elsewhere as well because
they just become accepted as best practice.
There's less gridlock. Weirdly in Europe,
you know, there're 27 countries in the
European Union, but they seem to be able to
get to a consensus on internet regulation
better than the United States can.
HAVEN: The EU is far ahead of the United States
in developing actual legislation. So the EU AI
Act uses a framework for regulating AI that is
risk based. It says essentially that we need to
assess the societal risk of a particular instance
of AI in order to decide how we regulate it.
SIERRA: Some European countries have
gone even further, in April of this year,
Italy briefly banned ChatGPT, saying that it
collects too much user data. And recent reports
show that Germany, France, and Ireland could
soon be following in Italy’s footsteps. And of
course China is a story unto itself.
CNBC Television: One of the key future
battles with China is over artificial
intelligence but one former Pentagon expert
says it’s already over, and China has won.
MSNBC: China has already declared its intent
to become the global leader in AI
by 2030 as the U.S. and European
Union fight to hold their ground.
CNBC International: Beijing may also be
interested in “monitoring or regulating” such
AI products to make sure “they are not being
used in ways that threaten national
security or social stability.”
SIERRA: China has framed AI
innovation as a national priority,
with the potential for AI development to add
$600 billion to its economy annually. But,
in contrast to the United States, China is
keeping tight control over AI development,
as it has in the past over other industries.
HAVEN: From a geopolitical perspective,
there's definitely this narrative that the
United States is in an AI Cold War with China,
that we are in this potentially existential race.
And existential not in the sense of snuffing out
humanity, but existential from a national security
and international sovereignty perspective. That
narrative is absolutely shaping the ways in which
we approach regulation in this country.
SIERRA: This past April, the Chinese
internet regulator released a draft
regulation on generative AI, like chatbots. In
general, the proposal focuses on transparency,
anti-discrimination, and respect for intellectual
property, though these rules would not constrain
the Chinese government itself. The regulation
also stipulates that output from generative AI
must “reflect the core values of socialism,”
a constraint that could shape how their AI
develops.
SIERRA:
Are we going to have to rely on each country
to make its own regulations? I mean, is there
a possibility of a global regulatory body?
HAVEN: You know, there is a possibility of a
global regulatory body.
SIERRA: There's always a
possibility really, yeah.
HAVEN: There have been calls from multiple places
for an international regulatory body. That strikes
me as really difficult to achieve if we don't have
a clear sense of our own regulatory structure, but
critically our own values in regulating AI.
MALLABY: People talk about having an equivalent to
the IAEA, the International Atomic Energy Agency,
which tries to set rules around the use
of nuclear power and sort of supervise and
prevent proliferation through inspections and so
forth. And I think that sort of international body
would be a good addition to the global system.
I think, though, that one thing which is obvious
for anybody who studies international relations
is that you tend to get to results through a
combination of supranational and national and
private sector initiative. And no one body is
going to be a silver bullet. So you're going
to need national regulation as well. And you're
going to need a lot of industries that think
actively about developing best practice and
self-regulate. I think the good thing here is that
there already is conversation going on between
industry and governments. There's conversation
between companies, although they are competitors,
they also talk about safety and ethics
and responsible AI with each other.
SIERRA: Do you think that countries
can or should push to limit private
development? Sort of force everyone into this
Manhattan Project model where everything is
done under the eye of the government?
MALLABY: I think we're just not in a place where
it's credible to believe that the government can
take over all AI development. That would take such
a radical act of nationalization and disruption.
I think that's probably too extreme. But I think
what you can do, and what's kind of happening
anyway is that there will be a huge amount of
dialogue between the AI developers and people
in government. And people in government are
already going to the obvious big developers,
Microsoft, Google, et cetera, and saying,
“You know, listen, we know that when you publish
AI research papers, these are downloaded in vast
numbers in China. Just be a bit selective about
what you're publishing, a bit careful.”
SIERRA: I've lived through a lot of the
emergence of the internet in my life,
and I don't really recall a moment where
regulators or “good guys” seemed to be ahead
of “bad guys” or the rogue actors. Do you
think that this will be the case with AI as
well? Has it been the case with AI as well?
HAVEN: There's a lot of literature and research
on what's called the pacing problem, which
is exactly what you're talking about. That
technological development tends to outpace
regulation, but in many ways that's less
about the regulation of the bad guys and
more about the regulation of the guys,
of the companies who have the greatest access to
data, compute, talent, and money, and who are,
you know, falling outside of regulatory controls.
So I would back up and say I think that we have
a pacing problem with, you know, regulating
theoretically well-intentioned companies or,
you know, capitalist markets. That said, we
know that humans will use technical systems
in all kinds of surprising ways, both,
you know, wonderful and entertaining and
also nefarious and adversarial. And so, I
think regulating with the idea that we're
only regulating the good actors or the sort of
known actors and not considering the adversarial
uses of AI would be a huge mistake.
SIERRA: One major concern that people have
is that very soon we won't know if a piece of
content: writing, news, music, et cetera, was
created by AI. Do you think there should be a rule
that AI always has to tell us that it's AI?
MALLABY: Yes. I think there's a question about
how you enforce the rule if some of the AI’s are
based in Russia or wherever. But here again, I
think the optimistic vision is that, you know,
the responsible players in AI are going to include
what they call watermarks, either in the music
that is generated, like computer generated music,
computer generated images, computer generated
text, all of these things will have signatures.
So you, as a normal internet surfer, could see a
great picture on some internet platform and then
click, you know, like an information button and
say who generated this? Was it a human? Was it
a machine? And if it's a machine, the machine
would reveal its identity to you. I think that's
a super useful protection against deep fakes. The
risk is of course, that responsible creators
of AI will do that, and irresponsible people
will be offshore and they won't, and the bad
actors will use the irresponsible versions of
AI. So then comes the question, what do you
do about that? I think this is all something
that's being discussed and worked out in real
time, but those are some of the indications
of where we might find a solution.
SIERRA: There’s just so much to consider when
we look to the future of AI. And while the United
States may be ahead on the development, we’re way
behind on the regulation. The rules and guidelines
we establish today are likely to have profound
impacts on the future of society. Getting AI right
could be a very good thing, and getting it wrong
could be a very bad thing indeed. Almost everyone
on earth has an interest in getting it right.
SIERRA: What makes a responsible AI?
MALLABY: Part of it is designing it in such
a way that humans feel agency and feel that
they can understand what the AI is doing.
There's a whole field of trying to think of ways
to reduce the black box element of artificial
intelligence. So explainability is improved. So
when you’re given an output, you might be given A,
a confidence level around how confident
the algorithm is that it got that right
to B, maybe some indication of how it got to that
answer. There's a whole field now called alignment
within consumer computer science, which is to
align the machines with what humans want from
machines. And again, this is a sort of thing which
gives me some optimism that the people building
this stuff care about making it good.
HAVEN: I think that there is a very strong
desire to see a check on what feels like a runaway
industry that has amassed an enormous amount of
power and money and decision-making ability to
set the agenda on a technology that will impact us
all. And I think that we need to think about the
AI moment in that way, not as a moment of clamping
down and, you know, shrinking opportunity, but as
actually a moment of hugely increased opportunity
to think about the ways in which we can use a
technology like this to mitigate climate change,
to find new energy sources, to solve seemingly
intractable health problems. And I think that is
entirely possible, but I also think that it
requires societal investment and agency and
shaping that we don't have right now.
SIERRA:
For resources used in this
episode and more information,
visit CFR.org/whyitmatters and take a look at
the show notes. If you ever have any questions
or suggestions or just want to chat with
us, email at whyitmatters@cfr.org or you
can hit us up on Twitter at @CFR_org.
SIERRA: Why It Matters is a production
of the Council on Foreign Relations. The
opinions expressed on the show are solely
that of the guests, not of CFR, which takes no
institutional positions on matters of policy.
SIERRA: The show is produced by Asher Ross
and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer
is Markus Zakaria. Our associate podcast
producer is Molly McAnany. Our interns this
summer are Isabella Quercia and Jina Lim.
Special shout out to Noah Berman for his
production help on this two-parter episode.
SIERRA: Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor,
and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital
Officer. Extra help for this episode
was provided by Mariel Ferragamo.
SIERRA: Our theme music is composed by
Ceiri Torjussen. We’d also like to
thank Richard Haass, Jeff Reinke,
and our co-creator Jeremy Sherlick.
SIERRA: You can subscribe to the show on
Apple Podcasts, Spotify, Stitcher, YouTube
or wherever you get your audio.
SIERRA: For Why It Matters, this is
Gabrielle Sierra signing off. See you soon!